[Music]
in seniors gone wild news oh my god are
serious submitted by hello from Malaysia
hello hey bad behavior by senior
citizens reduce the number of bingo
games per month and that's exactly what
I imagined you know what my old people
the older they get they turn into
children again so the people are running
the place like these guys are [ __ ]
like poking each other tickling each
other grabbing each other's nipples and
then the people are like stop it if you
guys do this again we're gonna stop
bingo you're not getting any more
Metamucil and you're not gonna get to
see you're like taking a [ __ ] you don't
get black-and-white movies anymore it
was like that yeah your grandfather's
was scary
they take the hearing aids out them kid
here be double focus my queen ha ha ha
yeah so there's a Senior Center in
Massachusetts that they said that
they're fighting night bingo has been
getting out of control
why what do you mean what are they are
they drinking to or they're just like
getting too excited all the grandmas lay
on the table and then all the grandpa
takes shots whoo thing it feels like
that kind of out of control be like damn
but no it's tone down [ __ ] gone she
also make it grandma oh god there's a
[ __ ] naked ground more like Al before
all of our body oh my god do you need it
I don't know grandpa Polly would you
favorite rabbi you did okay yes
every muscle is associative asian yeah
you're on parabolic and hyperbolic did
or Bing gay all right for those units
DOMA yeah so what they're describing
their behavior to be is seniors banging
on doors of other rooms at the facility
that's funny
making people in for lunch when a ticket
is required and also [ __ ] look at
bug being rude
as involuntary hilarious leaving the
room a mess
cool rock stars and threatening egg
vehicles of volunteers upon learning
that bingo what bingo regularity was in
jeopardy it just sounds like disgusted
when a swell smoke just [ __ ] car at
your cars you take away my bingo I think
we're being looked up I am on the side
of the station what a threat do they
have testimonial videos of these people
I wish I would love to hear the threat
that'd be so awesome yeah there is
something shady going on it's like they
want them to just lay down and die like
let them have fun yeah appears if these
snuck some people in what's the big deal
what's the big deal in jail how many
friends do they have at this point
you're gonna mean I know I'm having to
have a lot of friends I love you there
probably be dead I mean how much money
are they losing by having one friend
come you know like it's not even that
much food seniors don't even eat a lot
yeah maybe it's more of a liability it's
more it's what their the way they're
reporting it's kind of like well it's
the fact that they're just being
[ __ ] to the staff so there's one
example there was um there was one
single player that yelled at a board
member of the senior center because the
board was meeting in the room that they
are going to have bingo prior to bingo
starting yeah but it was 11:15 and the
bingo doesn't started so until one get
to mercy yes boy roll don't analyze
though you know time goes slow so the
faster the older you get the faster you
yeah I think when you retired it goes
slow again gee I really do oh yeah like
for us it's going fast because we're
busy but then for someone that literally
has nothing to do that's like bingo so
important then time is like they're like
[ __ ] you love is going to happen okay
you guys better better be out of here
because I need my [ __ ] bingo
yeah we've been saying that this has
been happening a lot where a lot of like
bingo players get like super impatient
because they're trying to get their most
coveted seat because bingo lasts for
hours so you're just trying to make sure
that they have
that they want with the friends in the
same area so they're just like y'all
need to chill like there's a center
saying that they're [ __ ] up
that tells me there's not enough
stimulation if Bingle's the only [ __ ]
thing they got going for them if that's
the only thing they got going on they're
going to take that away I just feel like
this whole management needs to get
[ __ ] fired and you need new management
I knows what the [ __ ] they're doing they
need to get them doing something way
more productive like gardening yo
joining a gang no they are getting
unicycle no my calls are organized crime
even yeah I agree like reading this
story cuz a lot of it it's like from the
center's perspective I'm just like what
are you guys doing that makes them act
this way that yeah I feel like they're
not getting enough attention or does not
being enough time spent with them I
agree I saw this one documentary in
Okinawa they where they have the oldest
population they combine the seniors with
like some daycare elementary kids I
thought it's in Europe too
yeah and then they just bring them
together because they're both around the
same type of mind
they're both bored as [ __ ] samosa they
both [ __ ] their pants yeah they both
should surpass and grandmas love kids
and kids love grandmas and grandpas and
they just come together is dope I love
that they [ __ ] take care of each
other they should one-up it and partner
up with an animal shelter in the hut
poppies and kitties to play with yes and
they could all take care of each other I
think I'll be deaf I don't know what no
I think that's cute
what was it uh-huh I don't know I just
feel like there's just a lot of I I
wouldn't want to mix babies old people
with like animals so much [ __ ] on the
market about like five or six dollars
yeah they're old enough like it enough
to interact as an adult yeah so I five
six and then like a 80 year old and then
a dog yeah yeah they're not toddlers and
keeps world that's cool but I still
don't understand for me for me I just
wouldn't want to mix the two already
just cuz I feel like there's already a
lot of attention that need to be focused
on the
and the kids and then to have animals in
the mix I feel like that's a crazy
variable because you just don't know
what like kittens and puppies are gonna
do and I just that just makes me nervous
what's all the time kids are kind of
means because I remember I really mean I
would throw my cat's off of buildings
and [ __ ] so at five yeah I was just like
your kid you don't realize so maybe they
don't really like paintball on the tails
and stuff yeah cuz I hate it going to my
friend's house his little brother would
love to grab like like hot wheels are
hard toys and chuck it at your face if
you thought it was so funny when it hit
my nephew too and when we would buy and
present or gifts or toys or whatever I
would we have to test on each other like
[ __ ] just going to hurt who's gonna
[ __ ] throw it at us like what I mean I
sleep on it
everything's foam in his room yeah
what's his dog back [ __ ] huh just chuck
it out his chest they would learn that
[Music]
phase I just that was my cousin
you know Andy yeah so like I was a
little bit older I feel I was like 12
when she was born or something and that
she would throw these things in the
light but because she's a girl like it
was one it was cute and it was funny and
you're all she's I kind of like this
rambunctious tomboy or whatever and then
but they just started getting out of
hand because the harder she threw and
the more I was in pain the more joy she
felt so I grabbed what was 18 so what is
it one of the things that she's do I
grabbed it and I just went pink on her
forehead each other no like don't throw
again and she did after that did you
understood yeah so you got any lesson
good job delicious
so those seniors heard that they were
going to get their bingo instead of once
every week down says just twice a month
oh hell no once a week someone went
around and to get people with sign this
petition to get their bingo bags
epidemic I don't know how many wait wait
wait why can't they just organize bingo
on their own we got a book that room
yeah it's that multi-purpose room that
they mean is it a center or is it
homes or they call it a Senior Center
REO it looks like you have the
multi-purpose room in the center then
you got all the rooms around it so
everyone's always looking like this
and coming in with their walkers and
stuff like that they're slowly make
their way there for an order here's some
four hours to get from their room to the
center I want to get them they keep
occupied by another [ __ ] group
delight
these [ __ ] [ __ ] needing
group yup they don't need a [ __ ] room
yeah so now they're gonna do like this
black market under the table bingo
no well after you know getting that
petition signed this one person got like
72 signatures sign like on for the
position but they're saying that they
draw about 75 to 80 people so they were
like long I didn't get it everyone you
know but it but we got to tell those
people you got a vote they were pooping
when they were passing on a petition or
against punch back I mean we're getting
might have geysers relaxing but but
they're saying that we could that the
board members of that center that
they're going to be meeting again to
make sure that they still have their
bingo but they're also going to see if
it can change them like policies here
and there a different measurement to
control their bad behavior they're not
behaving bad management needs to get
fired you fire them so I'm here so they
could play Sims or some [ __ ] I don't do
something let them [ __ ] grow daisies
or something yeah
community little garden no cool give
them [ __ ] to do they only got bingo I
vote job for the finishes in community
hire I would create a senior cruise ship
they could be on this cruise ship till
they die oh [ __ ] I don't know about that
I know it's on a cruise ship like you
like when we went on like a little bunch
of old I mean I feel like cruise ships
bring the youth back I've never seen so
many old people party harder than me get
a power wheelchair that's true every
time that YMCA came up people just had
the energy in the scene and I was like
damn man I'm trying to go to sleep I'm
tired but y'all
by parting [ __ ] they had that [ __ ]
solid wall and hey do you share all
kinds of joints cracking on their
density dude I think I think that's what
needs to happen is a cruise ship is that
what you want to do for your golden
years just spend the rest of your days
it's a different generation I feel like
from them that's the thing you know you
do cruise ships you do the Love Boat
whatever I feel like for us we're a
different generation how do you see our
generation as seniors [ __ ] computers
in their home in the home that's it
gonna be very lonely done won't be on ur
iPad well no it's gonna be like wall-e
where we're just in these like chairs
with videos and stuff like that that's
the future none of us want to go out do
nothing I know but I'm gonna be cyborg
so it's okay hey guys thanks for
watching this episode if you want to
submit your own articles check out the
link in the description box below and if
you want to see more videos check them
out right over here
[Music]
you
[Music]